pues ya se han terminado estas
negociaciones las primeras después de
que los líderes mundiales se marcharán
de glasgow escocia hoy como bien lo
decía será el día dedicado a las
finanzas y al ok sharma el presidente de
la cope cnti 6 y ministro de energía del
reino unido- dijo estar que era
lamentable que no se hubiera alcanzado
el objetivo impuesto en 2009 de alcanzar
los 100 mil millones de dólares de
financiamiento por parte de países ricos
para ayudar a los países con menos
recursos económicos a conseguir que su
economía esté menos basada en economía
en combustibles fósiles y también para
que se puedan adaptar y mitigar los
efectos del cambio climático sin embargo
dijo sentirse cautelosamente optimista
de que este objetivo se va a poder
conseguir en 2022 ya que hubo nuevos
anuncios de compromisos de españa
irlanda y luxemburgo datos de la ocde
sin embargo dicen que no se bancan a
alcanzar hasta 2023 ya que en 2019 las
cifras eran de 80 mil millones de
dólares según a locke sharma fue un buen
comienzo sin embargo desde claver action
network una asociación de 1500
ambientales de la sociedad civil
critican la falta de detalles concretos
para ver cómo van a recaudar este dinero
para poder conseguir esas promesas de
los políticos sin embargo del sector
privado llegan noticias de 450
organizaciones que componen el 40 por
ciento de los recursos económicos del
mundo han prometido
130 millones de dólares en la próxima
década para ayudar a que las economías
estén basadas en energías más limpias